many of the biggest movies in history
have gone through extensive changes
before they hit the silver screen
usually the reasons for these changes
are easy enough to understand but
sometimes things can take a turn for the
truly bizarre considered by many fans
and critics to be a minor misstep in the
long-running James Bond series license
to kill was the first Bond movie not to
take its name directly from one of iain
fleming stories instead its title is an
obvious reference to James Bond's famous
mi6 license to smoke anyone he felt like
the problem is that the crux of the
movie story is that bond isn't an mi6
agent anymore something the film's
original title alluded to when you're up
to your ankles you're gonna beg for
telling me everything when you're up to
your knees you'll kiss my ass for
kidding
initially the movie was supposed to be
called license revoked as a not too
subtle nod to bonds change of fortune
the problem early test audiences in
America assumed that the title referred
to James Bond losing his driver's
license which paints an altogether more
wholesome view of a movie in which bond
basically drops a dude into a glorified
meat grinder eager to avoid audiences
making this mistake the studio arranged
for a hasty title change which meant a
bunch of marketing material that had
already been created featuring the
original name ended up being thrown
straight into the trash in early cuts of
the 2012 remake of the 80s teen
adventure Red Dawn the film revolved
around the concept of mainland America
being invaded by the Chinese originally
slated for a 2010 release the movie was
put on hold by MGM during a period of
financial turbulence at the studio and
when chinese state media caught wind of
the film via leaked script the situation
went from bad to worse China condemned
the movie's themes specifically its
plans to depict the nation as an
invading war machine that had to be
stopped by a plucky band of American
kids when I was overseas we were the
good guys we enforced order well now
we're the bad guys can we create chaos
to appease Chinese censors and
potentially have the film screened for
the increasingly lucrative Chinese box
office MGM paid to have all the Chinese
flags replaced with North Korean ones
using CGI unfortunately even after
making the change the movie was doomed
to Chinese exile upon the revised
version submission censors still review
to allow the movie to air in China
during the last Jedi in addition to
showing off his swollen pecs and paste
the Sith Pack kylo Ren debuts his
personalized Thai silencer outfitted
with giant missiles a giant laser cannon
and sporting an impossibly cool paint
job the ship cuts an imposing silhouette
that reminds the audience bang kylo
Ren's enemies of the first orders power
it was also changed because of a
children's toy an early concept art
Ren's Thai silencer sported missiles
that were housed on the ship's underside
ready to be deployed and fired as needed
however according to director Rian
Johnson during production he received a
prototype toy version of the ship from
Hasbro and noticed that the missiles had
been mistakenly mounted on its wings
surmising that it'd be easier to just
change Ren's ship in the film using CGI
rather than redesign the toy itself
Johnson alerted the VFX team about the
alteration and it was corrected with the
audience and on the wiser eraser is a
mid-90s Arnold Schwarzenegger action
film that received disappointing reviews
nevertheless the film is chock-full of
all the schlocky Schwarzenegger II
goodness you'd expect from one of the
stars films including an action scene
during which he endlessly fires two
hyper powerful future guns into a crowd
of faceless bad guys and another that
finds him shooting a large CGI alligator
in the face the plot revolves around a
company called cyrez that's trying to
manufacture the APRA mentioned future
guns to sell on the black market
originally the company was called Cyrax
because well how future istic does that
sound however just before the film was
set to be released a texting computer
chip manufacturer called cyrix caught
wind of its and threatened to sue warner
brothers because they didn't want to be
associated with a fictional company that
made cool future guns not wanting to
fight the issue in court warner brothers
begrudgingly spent a reported 1 million
dollars changing the name to cyrez with
dubbing and cgi way to be spoil sports
cyrix
in the Stephen King novel that Stanley
Kubrick's The Shining is based on most
of the stories action takes place in
room 217 however in the film adaptation
this is changed to 237 which confused
fans of the book giving Kubrick's
reputation for perfectionism as it
turned out while the change was made by
Kubrick he was only acting on the wishes
of the timberline
the hotel where the movie was filmed the
Timberline didn't have a room 237 but
they really did have a room 217 and
management didn't want their guests to
be scared of staying in that particular
room after the movie was released
according to author James Howard Kubrick
agreed to change the number largely as a
favor to the lodge and amusingly in
direct contrast to their initial fears
about the film and its potential impact
on the rooms popularity the Timberline
would later report that despite Kubrick
changing it room 217 is still the most
commonly requested in the entire hotel